Human existence is scary and confusing.
A few hundred thousand years ago,
we became conscious and found
ourselves in a strange place.
It was filled with other beings. We
could eat salmon, some could eat us.
There was liquid stuff we could drink,
things we could use to make more things.
The daytime sky at a tiny yellow
ball that warmed our skin.
The night's sky was filled
with beautiful lights.
This place was obviously made for us.
Something was watching over us.
We were home. This made everything
much less scary and confusing,
but the older we got, the more we
learned about the world and ourselves.
We learned that the twinkling lights
are not shining beautifully for us.
They just are.
We learned that we're not at the center
of what we now call the universe and
that it is much,
much older than we thought.
We learned that we're made of many
little depth things which make our bigger
things that are not dead for some reason
and the we're just another temporary
stage in a history going
back over a billion years.
We learned in all the,
we live in a moist smack of Das to
moving around a medium size star.
It acquired region of one
arm of an average galaxy,
which is part of a galaxy group that we
will never leave and this group is only
one of thousands that together make
up a galaxy supercluster but even our
supercluster is only one in the
thousands that make up what we call the
observable universe. The universe
might be a million times bigger,
but we will never know.
We could throw words around like 200
billion galaxies or trillions of stars or
bazillions of peanuts,
but all of these numbers mean nothing.
Our brains can't comprehend these
concepts. The Universe is too big.
There is too much of x,
but size is not the most troubling
concept we have to deal with.
It's time or more
precisely the time we have.
If you're lucky enough to live to 100
you have 5,200 weeks at your disposal.
If you're 25 now that you
have 3,900 weeks left,
if you're going to die at 70
then there are 2,340 weeks left.
A lot of time,
but also not really.
And then what your biological
processes will break down.
And the dynamic pattern that is,
you will stop being dynamic.
It will dissolve until there is no,
you left some belief that there is a
part of us we can't see or measure,
but we have no way to find out.
So this life might be yet and
we might end up dead forever.
This is less scary than it sounds though.
If you don't remember the 13.7 5 billion
years that went by before you existed
than the trillions and trillions and
trillions of years that come after,
we'll pass in no time. Once you're
gone, close your eyes count to one.
That's how long forever feels.
And as far as we know,
in the end the universe itself will
die and nothing will ever change again.
Our videos induced existential dread
in many people and the last few minutes
probably haven't helped.
So for once,
we want to offer a different way of
looking at these sex and unscientific
subjective point of view. The philosophy
of course cause act if you want,
please take it with a grain of salt.
We don't know any more about
human existence than you do.
We count a existential dread
with optimistic Neil Islam.
What do we mean by that?
Well, to summarize,
it seems very unlikely that 200 trillion
trillion stars have been made for us.
In a way it feels like the cruelest
joke in existence has been played on us.
We became self aware only to realize
this story is not about us. One,
it is great to know about electrons and
the powerhouse of the cell doesn't do a
lot to make this less depressing.
Okay,
but so what you and you get one
shot at life which is scary,
but it also sets you free.
If the universe ends in heat death,
every humiliation you suffer
in your life will be forgotten.
Every mistake you made
will not matter in the end.
Every bad thing you did will be voided.
If our life is all we get to experience,
then it's the only thing that matters.
If the universe has no principles,
the only principals relevant
to the ones we decide on.
If the universe has no purpose, then
we get to dictate what its purpose is.
Humans will most certainly ceased to
exist at some point, but before we do,
we get to explore ourselves
and the world around us.
We get to experience feelings. We get
to experience food, books, sunrises,
and being with each other.
The fact that we're even able to think
about these things is already kind of
incredible. It's easy to think of
ourselves as separated from everything,
but this is not true.
We are as much the universe as a neutron
star or a black hole or a nebula.
Even better actually we are.
It's thinking and feeling the
sensory organs or the universe.
We are truly free in a
universe sized playground,
so we might as well aim to be happy
and to build some kind of utopia in the
stars. It's not as if we
found out everything there is
to know. We don't know why.
The rules of the universe are as they are,
how life came into existence,
what life is.
We have no idea what consciousness is
or if we are alone in the universe,
but we can try to find some answers.
There are billions of stars to visit,
diseases to cure people, to help,
happy feelings, to be experienced,
and video games to finish.
There is so much to do.
So wrapping up,
you've probably used up a good
chunk of the time available to you.
If this is our one shot at life,
there is no reason not to have
fun and live as happy as possible.
Bonus points if you make the life of
other people better, more bonus points.
If you help build a galactic human empire,
do the things that make you feel good.
You get to decide whatever
this means for you.